what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch today from new
rock stars the exact moment king killed Iron
Man revealed John how are you how goes holding
down the fort of the real reject it is the
biggest responsibility of my life thank you
for asking how are you sir good I'm taking it
super easy I'm really happy to hear that from
you guys leave a like if you can that'd be very
much appreciated also that's all let's go to it
[Music] welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston with King the Conqueror on Deck as the
big bad of Marvel Phase 5 and phase six a
man who in quantumania footage displays a
terrifying amount of amnesia for the amount of
Avengers he has killed new visual Clues from
Loki revealed in a book have confirmed that Kang
variants are sadistically collecting trophies from
the adventures that they've conquered We Begin oh
cool what season one ended but now as we've begun
to learn a lot more about Kang and quantumania
footage and Loki season 2 footage a trailer for
which that I saw at d23 and it will hopefully drop
online before the end of the year we can actually
deduce that Kang absolutely killed Iron Man Tony
Stark in another timeline and in fact based off of
what we know about Kang probably just killed him
in only one timeline and I think it might explain
why there was no Iron Man in the Illuminati in
Universe 838 of Multiverse of Madness oh they're
cool you've killed Tom Cruise lucky the art of the
series includes one page showing concept art if he
main study in the Citadel said decorator
Claudia bonfe gives us a brand new insight
into what exactly we're looking at here she said
that he remains has a collection of Antiquities
the shells are full of collections that he's
brought back from throughout the Universe and
they are all related to either a cultural thing or
time or just anything that's interesting or unique
throughout the Universe I didn't want to put any
bright colors in there it was all black and gold
marble so I stuck with wood tones that would
work maybe something that had a little bit of
a caramel feel to it a warmth and then was mixed
in with Metals okay all right here we go all right
attention really to what is happening in the scene
and not that dressing but what is your job then if
you're not breaking down every single thing on
those walls there across piece of gold or bronze
or any neighboring color you should be drawing
Clues from we didn't know every single Easter egg
you're the only one on the internet that can do it
all those gold cracks are just made of melted Iron
Man suits oh nice try Claudia you did amazing work
on this series I'll give you that but the psychos
here on YouTube are going to find Easter eggs
no matter how hard you try to hide and promise
there's a crown with two fangs or horns maybe a
headpiece of a Loki and then over on the right
is a chalkboard that in the series had Newtonian
calculus equations on it but here in this concept
art depicts geometry and trigonometry reminding
us of Spider-Man no way home when Peter Parker
managed to defeat Doctor Strange In The Mirror
Dimension by trumping Strange's focus on calculus
with a simpler trick of geometry that calling
back Spiderman homecoming when the first class
of Peter Parker's day was either trigger physics
and Peter knew the answer to the problem because
it involved the kind of trajectory equations
that Peter has to do in his head every day when
he whips around with his webbing I mentioned
all this because oh wow bad news okay he also
statistically most likely killed a Spider-Man
at some point too now all these trophies remind
us of uncanny Avengers number eight the King
Dynasty two thousand years in the future where
Kang shows off a trophy room filled with relics
that he snatched him across them all oh that's
really cool multiple cap Shields multiple Iron Man
helmets a mjolnir magnitude arms Spider-Man mask
Electro Daredevil gear they literally everything
Marvel is in this room but back in the Citadel
over on the left he remains as a telescope which
is interesting because what exactly is there to
look at from The Citadel other than the sacred
timeline orbiting around it meaning this Kang
variant might physically look out at moments in
history using this device to inspect what parts
of the timeline must be adjusted or pruned this
telescope now the latest trailer for Ant-Man the
WASP quantumania show Scott Lang meeting Kang
the Conqueror who offers him a deal to give him
back time if he'll steal back something that
was stolen from him Scott says he's an Avenger
and Kang asks you're an Avenger have I killed
you before so akang definitely killed an Iron
Man at some point in some timeline you see the
thing is about that line though that a lot of
people are not reading into at all because yeah
sure there's like plow leaks out of different
and stuff and I don't really know the details on
it the fact that he does not remember who Ant-Man
is at all in that moment shows that he probably
never killed an Ant-Man before so maybe Ant-Man
is the one who can ultimately outsmart and defeat
gang think about it if he's the main villain in
the first movie out of phase five which is an
Ant-Man movie how cool would it be if it came
back full circle people the King Dynasty or
Secret Wars were ant-man's ultimately the one
to take him down well that would be cool because
then it would mean that the Sandman movie beyond
the importance of just having Kang in it and
Kang's plans you know fully revealed and and
microscoped in a pond would mean that yeah Scott
Lang actually has a fighting chance to be the
one to make a significant difference in this
fight even though you know Kang is definitely
going to appear Beyond quantumania he remains
as an Iron Man helmet but that doesn't mean
he remains was the one to kill that Iron Man
he who remains was just the king variant who
used Elias to defeat all the other kangs and in
that last multiversal war he remains could have
collected these trophies from other defeated
Kings or even inherited this whole Citadel
from one of the other kings because remember
that broken statue in the lobby there was a
past struggle in this location now if we assume
several Tony Starks across the Multiverse had
similar life trajectories at least the way Tony
Stark was depicted in one died in like so many
what-if episodes Nexus moment where it would
be the most important for Kang to stop Tony
dead in his tracks Tony certainly came close to
death in many moments in the kandar province in
Afghanistan flying through that wormhole in
2012 Adventures fighting Thanos and infinity
war on the guardianship at the beginning of
end game but I've always believed that the
most important moment in Tony Stark's life as it
pertains to Kang nathana Richards A Thousand Years
Later in the 31st century was this moment this
time in the Mobius strip trip inverted please
[__] yes Tony Stark's discovery of time travel
via Quantum navigation I firmly believe that
this moment and Kang are connected I love you
3000 Nathaniel Richard's birth year being 3
000 something and yeah I also
believe that he remains actually
Ultimate Easter egg Nathaniel Richards needed Tony
Stark to make this discovery in the year 2023 so
that a thousand years later Nathaniel could build
on Stark's research and master the technology of
time travel and Multiverse hopping if you think
about it that way that actually makes it pretty
precarious for Kang to ever try to kill Iron Man
because he's gonna be neither than that badly to
discover his Missing Link of time travel for him
there would not be many opportunities after that
Discovery for Kang to kill Tony considering it
led directly to the Time Heist and endgame in
the Battle of Earth in which Tony's fight with
Thanos led to his death anyway so I think the
likeliest universe in which Kang killed Iron
Man was actually the one Universe we've seen
so far in which Tony was mysteriously absent
Universe 838 of Multiverse Madness a university
we know had some presence of Tony Stark at
some point in its history with Ultron Sentry
Stark Tech walking around but at the time we
visited it no longer had a Tony sitting on
the Illuminati Deus there was one open seat but
looking back I think it's likelier that open seat
belonged to either the 838 t'challa or Namor or
maybe balzer the brave I just love where you're
going with this so far because of the fact
that it's connected to Iron Man oh there's
a possibility Iron Man's influence continues
that trajectory of some type of innovation
whether it be a rise to a hero or create some
type of technological advancement that creates
an Ultron but then him creating something
with time travel or discovering something
that leads to gang Dynasty like it's it's kind
of funny and ironic at the same time I really
do uh like what you're doing to justify to help
out Marvel because you know when they're like
oh yeah we didn't have an Iron Man in here and
let's just use what Eric Voss is saying in this
video and that'll explain not just because
we couldn't get a junior to come back or Tom
Cruise let's just use that it's gonna say yeah
it's the perfect excuse for not having a Tom
Cruise cameos I don't know it just couldn't
happen you know it had to happen this exact
right time and you know on the timeline where
we chose to go with Doctor Strange just didn't
work out he was already dead if 838 Tony Stark
was killed by Kang that would explain why the
why the side effects of dark hole dreamwalking
and not side effects of any time travel Mechanics
for them Multiverse awards are caused
by dark magic not 31st Century science
838 seems to be the one Universe without
vertical vertical time travel no Charles
Xavier did reference himself an X-Men Days
of Future Past so who knows it might have
consciousness-based time travel as a rule
to it have I thought more about this than
the filmmakers have at this point yeah
definitely that's what I was good again
whether by future scientists using technology
or by Wizards and witches using an evil spell
book in dark magic the Multiverse is destined
one way or another to collapse into chaos it's
almost like neither of these things are really
causing it it's just gonna collapse on itself
anyway and incursions are the fate of all of us
but I want to ask you do you think we'll ever
see a killing Montage in which Kang Slaughters
Avengers I mean I know marvel did get cold feet
and removed Gore doing the same thing to the
Gods in Thor love and thunder My Hope Is that
they actually cut that so that it would have
more impact when Kang does it to Avengers in
Kang Dynasty why would that have more impact
both would have impact Gore would be killing
Gods on Avengers so I think uh you're helping out
Marvel well when we get so that way Marvel can be
like that's why Gore didn't kill all these Gods
because we wanted it to have more of an impact
when uh Kang's killing off all the Avengers
yeah montages of of characters Mass killing
other characters we gotta tone it down so the
gang still looks formidable but now I think
you're actually pretty right on about that theory
you know even if it is something that Marvel can
just use it I I like the idea of that's that's
the narrative that they go with ultimately it's
actually it works quite well and I like I said
I like the idea of like starting with Tony Stark
and his presence of consequences just lingers
throughout the eternity of the MCU it's really
it's neat to me all right guys what do you think
about the city leave your thoughts down below you
can subscribe to new Rockstar subscribe to the
real rejects leave a like last but not least
Anissa Oliver we are going through the first
part of November to honor our most loyal super
sexy rejection you must be one of the sexiest
of them all big 5-0 not just physically but
longevity wise too that's right 50 months you
have been with us sexier over time 50 months
that's crazy and not to mention I remember during
the pandemic you were like contributing like 300
per live stream it was insane how much your
credit I don't know where all that money was
coming from you must have won multiple lotteries
or something like that or you just went into the
negatives and now you regret it either way Anisa
we have talked with you so many times you got to
hang out with you in person and uh you were just
an absolute delight and through all the time of
talking with you before we actually got to hang
out with you in person gotta say you were even
cooler in person than you than the person would
be imagining you to be talking via the Internet
so yeah good job you're an amazing Spirit an
amazing Soul we love you and forever be in our
heart and someone will just never ever ever in a
million years ever forget ever thank you [Music]